gordon ramsay is heading to
kwazulu-natal south africa
to learn the secrets of zulu cuisine but
how the region developed some of its
signature dishes
reveals a deeper and darker history
in just one stroll through a spice
market in durban south africa
you can find the perfect marriage of
indo-african flavor
from the touch of spice and a fresh
usatini to the powerful heat found in
traditional durban curry
but how did indian spices find their way
into south african cuisine
the zulu palette is very simplistic but
we do add a touch of chili every now and
then right because that sort of culture
has infiltrated
throughout the region as of 2019
there are approximately 1.5 million
people of indian descent
currently living in south africa in 1860
the british began bringing in indians to
what is now known as the kwazulu-natal
province
this wave of people were predominantly
indentured servants
who came to work in south africa's
sugarcane industry
india banned indentured labor
immigration to the province in 1911
but with the end of indentured servitude
came the beginning of apartheid in 1948
the sanctioned racial segregation and
political and economic discrimination
against non-whites prior to and during
the apartheid era
south african indian cuisine came from
indians reworking their own classic
dishes with the ingredients they had
available
and combining the elements in new ways
take one of durban's signature dishes
durbin curry
when the first groups of indentured
servants came to the kwazulu-natal
province
ingredients that they were long
accustomed to were scarce
to make meals stretch local varieties of
potatoes were added into the curry
which acted as a base to the abundant
amount of meat and poultry available
durbin curry also garnered its iconic
red hot flavor profile
due to its incorporation of indian hot
chilies
oh my god that's hot yeah but i thought
you look like a spicy guy to me
another example durbin's bunny chow
the meal is made to be eaten with your
hands and it was a more durable spin on
indian bean curry with roti
it consists of a loaf of white bread
with the center hollowed out
and stuffed with curry several origins
tie the dish to the indian working class
and the prejudiced conditions of the
apartheid era a popular origin suggests
that it was used as a way to serve
people of color who were forbidden to
eat inside cafes and restaurants
non-white customers had to order their
food to go at the door
and the dense bread served as a robust
and portable container
from indentured servitude to apartheid
indian cuisine in south africa was not
just used as a way to fill hungry
bellies
it was used as a way to preserve a
culture and helped create a new one
in the process
[Music]
want to see more from my uncharted
adventures please click here to watch
more clips
you